at the big game in Minneapolis in the
Honda Studios good to see you Brian
Billick I gotta buy a Honda to get to
Stu you in LA no no no all you got to do
is just enter but you haven't in already
you can't you can't I don't think I
don't know the official rules but I
think no because we because we're so
tired I know could go just like that
that's a tough act to follow
it's like following Ray Lewis out of the
tunnel they used to introduce then ray
would go smoke right and then and then
I'm supposed to come out afterwards now
we did that for about three games I go I
ain't doing that did you like that dance
ray is you know what at Fir I'm kind of
old school and I kind of thought oh boy
are we but then what I came to find out
I've spent eight years nine years
watching the opponent's mesmerised and
you know those coaches the night before
now look when Ray Lewis I don't want you
I'm we're all gonna meet Oh Jeff fish
used to take his team down the other end
and try to talk to him and get
distracted and the guys would be going
watching Ray Lewis come on they couldn't
help themselves it was you just
compelled to watch it and it definitely
would psyche out some opponents that it
was on his team so we changed that one
by the way so let's let's break this
down best we can here in the again man
versus food coach's conversation for
Super Bowl 50 - what do you think the
Philadelphia Eagles if there's one thing
Doug Peterson sitting there with either
one of his coaches saying we must do
this what is the this you know the good
news is Philadelphia has all the talent
and has shown they can do what it takes
to beat the New England Patriots they
really do if I'm done Peterson and you
can go through the litany of and we all
have it in the list of in your breakdown
care what do you got to do to beat Tom
Brady in the Patriots okay you got to
put pressure on Brady you got to keep
him under 35% on third down can't give
up big plays you got to get at least
seven hits hombre there's a whole litany
litany of things you've got to do the
problem is you got to do them all you
can't just do five out of the six six
out of it you got to do them all and so
what I would do is
I would get the clips and show my team I
used to love it when I had a team that
performed well thought I say okay I got
you now I got it on tape I've seen you
do the things we need to do now why
don't we do this every snap and and I'd
be doing that I'd be showing how we put
pressure on quarterbacks how you get
creative on turnovers how we keep teams
suppressed on third down
okay I've seen you do it I know we can
do it we got the talent now we got to do
it on Sunday is it true that that
Stokley past that you that was thrown to
start the scoring in in the Super Bowl
that you won against the Giants that you
knew that going into the week that if
Dilfer gets this look or we knew what
it's over it's a wrap it's all like this
week because what who did two best
receivers on the team Zach Hertz and
Gronkowski mm-hmm in fact on playbook of
Sean O'Hair and I did a bit on how you
have to account for the tight ends well
what does that do
the minute you start doubling tripling
bracketing someone like Gronkowski or
Zach Ertz
that opens it up mmm you know whether
obviously it's gonna be a Hogan or Kooks
and and for Philadelphia Aguilera or
whatever so you get that one-on-one
matchup so we knew that if we got down
in that situation and when it was just a
simple all go route that they were gonna
you know they were gonna focus on
Shannon Sharpe well we didn't realize
was there gonna be eight guys on Jeff
sharp huh and and Jason Sehorn got kind
of betrayed a little bit he thought he
was getting help over the top and and
Stokely beat him one-on-one down the
field so the quintessential Belichick /
Patricia take away the one thing that
you do best is is Zach Ertz in this game
you think yeah I always love that you
know I love the brilliance of Belichick
who is brilliant obviously greatest
coach ever I love you you said this
before say that line I know he's going
that whether they take away what you do
best compared to the rest of us which
means we're covering decoys to do that
but clearly if you leave with Tom Brady
and less so folks cuz he's still getting
familiar with Zach Ertz
but if if you leave a one-on-one matter
you have no one in your back end yes
that can match up one-on-one with
Gronkowski so the minute tom sees that
that's where he's going so it's like
I've always said I can stop whatever you
do well I can put eight nine guys in box
top
you run I can I can shut I don't care if
it's Jerry Rice I can shut him down
I can double I can triple I can bracket
but at what costs where the other one on
water and that's where they get you well
I'm Brian Billick in the man vs. food
coaches conversation I'm here on the
Rich Eisen show and also on part of the
C key gap which we'll talk about a
second that the Eagles don't have to
scheme their way to brady would you
agree with that absolutely and that's
and that's usually how you can win it's
a recipe for braiding nothing away from
them but the two guards for annoying
Lynn Tunis and Mason obviously good
players but they need help that Center I
did a bit on playbook again where
whoever doesn't get the help one-on-one
when you're talking about Fletcher Cox
they can bring Brandon Graham down the
walk Kendricks up they have the assets
that that and because where is it
typical how do you get to Brady how do
you get hits how do you move them on the
spot bring pressure up the middle so you
know they're gonna account for that but
again it's like anything if I have to
account for you on the edge or on the
inside then what am I you know what
happens on the edges coming at you and
and Philadelphia Philadelphia has the
people and the talent to match up with
what they have to do to beat New England
offensively and defensively but
everybody's got to show up and part of
the reason why you got the gig in
Baltimore is the offense you coordinated
here in this town just lighting it up to
to record numbers what are you seeing of
Doug Peterson also who's trying to match
what you did was just a win a Super Bowl
in a second year what is he doing with
foals with this offense that is unique
in your eyes you have to be impressed
it's one thing to come into the Super
Bowl with a backup quarterback for us we
did it but but that transition happened
week week four or five friends so you
had a ramp-up time what they've done to
adapt from a carson wentz which is i'm
not gonna say it's a totally different
offense you know Carson Wentz's
Roethlisberger esque he you know shrugs
off the tackle runt make some plays and
and extends the play that way that's not
Nick fold so for them to build on their
their unique running game the rpoS we
saw the big play show up against
Minnesota
it's an evolution
and to do that over the last four or
five weeks and to end up in this game
I don't think Doug Peterson and his
group get enough credit and who would
you choose his coach of the year he
obviously got these two guys out there
saying hey obviously in the job that he
did but I think quite an inch it evolves
obviously and you know Bill Belichick
could get it every year but it's kind of
like a Nanna we can't give up in the
same way that Popovich and we say Phil
Jackson don't get an entity back in the
day sure but I think given what I just
said I think that as a coach their
ability I'm talking about Philadelphia
and Doug Peterson to adapt at the single
position that you can't lose the
quarterback and to do that in the last
few weeks of the season parlay that
through as an underdog in the divisional
round the championship game and now in
the Super Bowl I think that to me that's
that's the that's the one that puts him
over the top
tell me about SeatGeek what people can
do with the snow and it's not obviously
in the Superbowl Philly fans I did show
this morning in Philadelphia and they're
they're really challenging we got a you
know we got it we got to show up in
force you into the secondary ticket Mart
you got to go to see geek.com
they have a thing on the app seat
geek.com backslash Super Bowl ticket
tracker it's awesome it's like watching
the stock market they've got the trends
over the last couple years in terms of
when do you buy when do you wait how
long when does it fall off the Gideon
price now is well over $4,000 the
average price and it is you know it's
it's moving there's the one guys spend a
hundred and said you spend 175,000
dollars on one ticket that had to be you
right definitely not me not no but no I
mean anybody you go at its whether it's
NHL whether you're going to NBA if
you're looking for tickets I don't know
how you go to seek e-comm gives you all
the information need and every
transactions guaranteed it's guaranteed
hey look we use it we use it all the
time for concerts you know I took my
family to Hamilton in Los Angeles using
the C key cap but I haven't been on it
for the Super Bowl
the question I have for you before I let
you go is if I'm plus one in the
commissioner's suite mm-hmm and I have
to choose either one of these two guys
is there any algorithm whoa
on the app that can help me choose
between the two of them Wow Ryan you got
the clean look versus the drug lord I
mean
a cop or job or whatever like got out or
something yeah l/2 phone not by the way
he just called you l/2 phone not Delta
phone very good thanks for coming by and
real associate that you got it Brian
Billick again can be seen on NFL Network
on our playbook here on behalf of
SeatGeek
and then again was kind enough to join
us in our coaches conversation brought
to you by man vs. food casey web takes
steps up to the table with gusto
traveling to the Ozarks to take on the
goliath a massive cupcake equal to 20 to
regular-size cupcakes oh my gosh
then off to Philly for the epic classic
whale challenge a 13 pound bagel
sandwich stuffed with cream cheese
salmon white fish tomatoes and onions
ooh man vs. food only on Travel Channel
Mondays at 9:00 on Travel Channel JB
Smoove when we come back we'll start
reviewing some of the questions that he
did not ask that would left on the JB
Smoove cutting room flow from last night
before the aforementioned Shawn O'Hara
and Kurt Warner joins us in our number
three that's how we're rolling here on
the rich Hassan show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience